amen
[Music]
some monsters call to mind very specific
images
their iconic on-screen personas
overshadow their earlier histories I'm
talking about Frankenstein and his
creature Dracula the Invisible Man The
Wolf Man The Mummy
why is this Universal Pictures
[Music]
these famous Universal monster faces
inspired Decades of Halloween costumes
and make up a distinctive brand of
horror that defined early Hollywood
Cinema with strategic decisions in
wardrobe and special effects uniform
marketing Innovative cinematography and
casting that turned everyday actors into
Stars Universal Pictures forever changed
the game for on-screen monsters
foreign
at the turn of the 20th century early
silent horror films were largely Macabre
European Creations featuring ghosts
skeletons and wizards set against Gothic
backdrops the 1922 German film Nosferatu
was a fitting fulfillment of the Eastern
European vampire's Legacy and the first
horror film with an original score
[Music]
laughs
but what is now considered to be the
canonical period of horror Cinema didn't
come about until Universal emerged as a
Powerhouse Motion Picture Studio founded
in 1912 Universal film Manufacturing
Company initially saw critical and
financial success but like most of
America's struggled during the Great
Depression the solution to the Studio's
woes came in an unexpected form monsters
Universal's 1930s business strategy
started with a plan to make movies on as
tight a budget as possible and horror
fit the bill nicely the elements of
Gothic storytelling combined swimmingly
with the low lighting and imaginative
camera tricks that disguise budget
conscious sets unknown actors could be
concealed behind creative makeup effects
and hiring veteran European crew members
familiar with Gothic work made adapting
spooky stories for Hollywood easier with
the horrors of World War One and the
Great Depression America adopted
isolationist policies alongside
patriotism the Monstrous figure embodied
outside threats to these modern
constructions literally entering the
homes of families to tear them down from
the inside
[Music]
foreign
other common themes in Universal's
golden age of horror films included the
mad scientist hell-bent on playing God
the crumbling ancestral home or Castle
Class tensions failed marriages and
challenges to traditional gender roles
all admits a Gothic setting that alluded
to the historical but evoked present-day
fears a clever way for a studio to
appeal to what's already in the minds of
the people Universal's first Venture
into horror began in 1931 with the
infamous Undead bloodsucker himself
Dracula an established character in
folklore and literature both Dracula and
Nosferatu predate Universal's version
but Universal Dracula was the first to
legally adapt Brahm Stoker's famous text
after purchasing the rights to both the
novel and theater adaptation of Dracula
in 1929 Studio executive Carl Lemley Jr
green lit the film version with a few
caveats a tight budget prioritization of
elements from the stage play and a short
enough run time to use in a double
feature
Todd Browning was hired as director in
Charles D Hall was tapped for set design
but the studio still needed the star
while other more famous actors were
considered Bella Lugosi stood out as The
Logical Choice he had played Dracula on
Broadway and he was cheap and thank the
fates for that lugosi's portrayal of the
count and Universal's makeup and
wardrobe became the most influential
visual portrayal of vampires to this day
the pale skin dark slickback hair
aristocratic wardrobe and Infamous Cape
became the iconic depiction we
frequently associate with Dracula and
even though many modern interpretations
of vampires have moved past this
portrayal the countless imitations of
the universal brand not to mention the
Halloween costumes made this vampire an
icon
after the success of Dracula Universal
was thirsty for another home run they
offered prominent director James whale a
slew of different project Concepts to
choose from and he went with another
monster property Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein like Dracula before it the
movie's success hinged on the commercial
appeal of the monster whale insisted on
casting Boris Karloff a noted but under
recognized character actor as the
creature the neck bolts the exaggerated
brow and the suit were a notable
departure from Mary Shelley's original
creation yet the emotion that Shelley
wrote Into the character was still
present thanks to Karlov Universal's
interpretation would Define both the
actor and Shelley's character into the
21st century he can't have Frankenstein
take care
and in the Frankenstein film's final
iconic Face-Off between Henry and his
creature Universal continued to use
Innovative cinematography as a Hallmark
of the genre when the two gaze at each
other through the spinning wheel of the
windmill the slat's broken revelation of
their faces mimicking a film projector
and its precursor the zoetrope
Frankenstein was the first movie
promoted by a studio as a horror picture
and that decision was not met without
resistance primarily from Catholic and
conservative leaders critics condemned a
controversial hanging scene and some of
the film's dialogue as heretical trying
to address these concerns Universal
included a unique prologue to the
feature condemning Frankenstein's
actions and warning the audience of what
they will see we are about to unfold the
story of Frankenstein
a man of science
sought to create a man after his own
image
without Reckoning upon God
still some newspapers refused to publish
ads for the film and censors demanded
edits but the saying any publicity is
good publicity worked here made for less
than three hundred thousand dollars
Frankenstein outperformed Dracula
grossing 12 million dollars domestically
and Universal had another successful
monster in 1932 Universal Drew
inspiration from recent events the
discovery of the tomb of King
Tutankhamun his shrunken mummified
corpse captured the world's attention as
did the rumored accompanying curse The
Mummy told a tale of forbidden love
using the now recognizable Boris Karloff
as a titular character with a powerful
score and clever shots of miniature sets
viewers were transported to an exotic
interpretation of Egypt that paid homage
to the undercurrent of magic that fueled
so many of film's earliest Gothic
stories like its Universal precursors
The Mummy cinematic creativity
significant contributed to its
historical permanence pioneering
cameraman Carl papa front moved the
camera in ways previously unseen he
freed the camera from the typical static
tripod
strapping it to his chest for resting
angles and placing on a crane for
expansive frames
[Music]
in 1934 Hollywood instituted the
self-imposed haze code responding to
Industry scandals of the 1920s and
increasingly boundary challenging films
these censorship guidelines aim to
curtail anything that didn't depict the
correct standards of life as defined by
the rich man in charge at the time as a
result horror didn't disappear on screen
but became a bit more subdued Universal
in spite of the haze code however still
marketed their films as shocking meant
to astound and horrify which continued
to draw in audiences Universal went on
to add the Invisible Man and the
Werewolf of London to their horror
lineup bringing striking and memorable
special effects to the screen not to
mention two more iconic monsters
the monster genre couldn't solve all of
Universal's Financial struggles burdened
with debt Universal was bought out by
the standard Capital Bank in 1936 and
the existing Studio heads were canned
new execs cut budgets further
prioritizing musicals and halting
production on new horror content leading
to an exciting development the
introduction of the horror sequel eager
to capitalize on their earlier successes
in the genre Universal produced a whole
host of sequels Bride of Frankenstein
Dracula's daughter son of Frankenstein
The Invisible Man Returns the mummy's
hand the mummy's tomb and Son of Dracula
these burgeoning franchises were
financially strategic and further
established Universal's looming presence
in horror Cinema using a now established
cast and crew from makeup artists to set
designers the visual style of the
Universal horror film stayed consistent
and immediately recognizable
repeated Visual and Technical cues like
violent storms operating room or lab
sets off-screen female screams large
ancestral homes heavy use of Shadows and
creative cinematic framework solidified
the style
also in the 1940s Universal introduced
back-to-back crossover films to the
industry Frankenstein meets The Wolf Man
House of Frankenstein and House of
Dracula these in-universe collaborations
put the recognizable figures of
Frankenstein's creature Dracula The Wolf
Man The Mad Doctor and the Hunchback
assistant together on screen like an
Avengers Style universe with fewer rules
and no shared history in the Years
following the conclusion of World War II
moviegoing audiences seem to lose their
appetite for monster movies perhaps
needing a break from violence and Horror
in general they opted for more uplifting
content at the box office
the monster movies that were made during
this period backed away from horror
elements and leaned into the comedic
potential of the genre in the 1950s
while Universal Studios now Universal
International continued to produce
horror films they prioritized science
fiction in response to world events and
audiences shifting favor while the
quality of these films is debated there
is little denying that the decade
contributed at least one more unique and
iconic Universal monster
the Creature from the Black Lagoon
they marketed the film as the strangest
science fiction Thriller of them all
hoping to attract audiences enthralled
with the newly popular genre and who
were comfortable with monster stories
from the previous two decades
this monster isn't based so much on
existing lore but does rely on a
familiar monstrous human Trope set in
the Amazon the half fish half-human
monster struggles with very human
feelings of isolation and loneliness
[Music]
all right
called the Gillman the notable and
beautifully designed character suit and
sophisticated makeup under the direction
of noted actress and special effects
artist Millicent Patrick stand up as a
Hallmark of Universal's Monsters the
film was also notable for its underwater
photography not common for the time
it's not only a story that makes a
monster iconic all the creators who
contributed to Universal's classic
monsters did so with a specific
intention the writers actors directors
cinematographers Marketing Executives
special effects teams and costuming
departments they form the beating or
Undead heart of these Silver Screen
interpretations
I can't help but wonder if the
commercial and critical failure of some
of the reboot attempts is because they
strayed too far from the original
Universal monster formula take 2017's
the mummy big name A-list Hollywood
actors huge budgets two heavier Reliance
on digital special effects and an
obvious eye on franchise tie-ins it
neglected to honor the monster and its
meaning
in my opinion the magic of the original
films comes from the force creativity
necessary of a smaller budget the gothic
themes and letting the monster and its
story sell the film
2020's The Invisible Man Came closer to
this formula with a seven million dollar
budget a fraction of the mummies it uses
the absence of the monster's form
literally in favor of atmospheric
tension and some pretty horrifying
practical effects Universal's monsters
pushed back against societal Norms often
embracing the taboos that rigidly
defined conventional American social
structures of family patriarchy gender
and class while the Golden Age of
universal classic monsters is long gone
its Legacy has become monstrous itself
enduring frightening and always there to
scare our imaginations into action
Ahoy matey the newest show over on PBS
Origins will take you on an enlightening
Voyage Through the pirate history you've
been missing Rogue history unravels
historical myths on Earth's lost
narratives and champions unsung heroes
it's the pirate history you were never
told hit the link in the description and
explore it now
yeah
and action
oh no oh God
[Laughter]
I'm terrible